[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on peut revoir la chorégraphie
de notre père noël
[Applaudissements]
les boîtes de noël on est à quelques
jours de noël et nous avons ici des
mr-63 alors les scieries il ya des très
beaux cadeaux et il ya des cadeaux un
peu moins pourri quoi on va revoir la
liste des cadeaux et vous me direz à
tour de rôle qu'elle boiboite vous
voulez vous êtes 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
il règne à 12 boîtes dont il y en a une
et non de lambersart et que je n'ai pas
de boîte
alors eux il ya le délice de tunis c'est
un massage de mokhtar huile d'olive
harris à l'ats daniel box romantique
alors justement je crois que pour le
délicieux tunis on a une petite vidéo
pour ma rentrée on n'a pas de petite
vidéo pour vous d'accord pour daniel
pour la daniel boxe on a une petite
vidéo ont montré de quoi il s'agit envie
de faire grimper la température chute
laden boxe oh oui oh tu achètes cette
boîte est une boîte
donc c'est la sensation garantie jour
gens me jeter et dire que c'était sur
france télévisions service public a bien
changé le plâtre de castaldi dédicacé à
c'est une place où il embrasse
d'ailleurs le dr opérateurs atos tube de
rennes et des les huiles essentielles de
maxime guennic pour un peu voir hier
gars ont beau cadeau une trottinette et
ouais en journée de participation dans
les frangins de ses huit c'est à dire
vous fait toute la journée fête gym
direct vous faites une chronique chez
leymergie vous faites le soir benhaim
vous fait toute la journée toute la
journée et après normalement le
lendemain vous êtes viré le volet
animation d'un prime time c'est thomas
qui gagne en prime time et à vendredi
juste avant balances ton post
c'est eux non mais non au moins un
honneur de vous avoir juste derrière moi
alors je ne sera pas mathieu elle soit
sanou naciri lors en service un
chroniqueur tandem magique ça si vous
avez envie de me faire chier c'est
vraiment le cadeau examens visent à
celui ci je voudrais que je voudrais je
vous appellerai vers 3 4 heures du matin
damien vous emmerdez d'accord et si vous
voulez que je change une roue vient de
faire le ménage chez vous à 3 heures du
matin dans un pays aucun break et il ya
une console de jeux
[Applaudissements]
c'est dans cette année là d'accord c'est
le goal et là je l'aï si magnifique
merci alors les ferries les petits
outils il ya le cap-vert aussi voulait
être que l'animatrice de l'émission
pourquoi combien de saba c'est bon alors
vedove ai dit vous voulez qu'elle bottes
à la fête
c'est pourquoi la cette base à lhassa
mal non non non non on laisse rien n'a
rien teddy l'a7 c'est la secte ou ne
l'ouvré pas vous la gardez devant vous
alors vous vous taisez unanime voulez
quoi et bal à 5 alors la 5
s'il vous plaît
mettez un enfant alors qu'est-ce qu'on a
ou no stress alors là tu vois jusqu'où
malawi alors vous à quoi s'était dit
c'était des escarpins jean-patrick du
palais en dessin alors c'est ça que vous
voulez et la loi c'est là je ne sais pas
moi maintenant
bah quoi tu sais plus maintenant takashi
pas si j'aurai la 3g coup je prends à 10
l'a10 a dit j'espère qu'elle va voilà
j'espère jeu sera pas le prime time
delphine il adore le prime time
commence ensuite
alors moi je prendrais l'a6 à nancy
aimez-vous à cette coquine même quand il
tient de la dige prendre la chaîne sans
beaucoup d'éclat en dit long je prendrai
la sicile ou pas là
regardez ce sens que c'est là le sos
minnawi est fait peur par contre ça
n'est pas récent alors je vous aime
beaucoup que j'espère que ça va pas
tomber sur voie d'accès la maison et je
peux vous dire j'ai tout nettoyer des
solos et alors la numéro 8 c'est le blay
l'a86 c'est le seul c'est le seul qui
est poli celui-ci la numéro 8 qui vous
tenez vous bien les boîtes à lettres
remarque d'isabelle morini-bosc imany
elles sont belles allez les gars aient
bien la boîte 4 s'il vous plaît d'abord
votre carte à jouer en avant mais que
signifie cette mascarade
l'espagne a donné quoi là quatre pour
vous qui voilà deux merci bon niveau là
de balorre moi du coup les photons des
par hasard ainsi mme bah c'est ainsi du
mois la fois beaucoup à ça pas faux
paraît pas tout à l'heure par hasard oui
à la une la une il ya mathieu delormeau
qui peut rentrer un merci ne va pas lui
faire une entrée de stars n'ont plus les
théories sociales gens qui me va se
mettre la main viendront te vois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
je ne cache pas qu'on a plus de tabouret
si la banane à rio et tout ce qui suit
toute la place de l'inviter l'autre à
marée haute ça y est ça va est ce que tu
peux prendre le club bavarois mais n'a
pas pourquoi il va pas la place de radio
il est bien la vérité ou la tâche on est
dans les bois brut alors qu'est-ce que
vous prenez la 11e regarde les cadeaux
des cadeaux qu'il me prend le cas des
cadeaux s'est vu ses buts à quatre
pattes chers ils évitent ya des cadeaux
qui a vu times alors qu'avec apple time
choisir vas-y devez vous reconnaissez de
[ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
là
il faut la neige et famille on devenir
madame je suis dit cette crise monsieur
il a rien fait comment ça m'insupporte
ans et souffre alors vous avez toujours
boîte
je vais commencer à ouvrir sa boîte mail
à m vous avez choisi la boîte 5 trucs de
ouf
attendu à semble maintenant bien comme
about a mano entre les médias vous ce
que vous gardez là c'est sûr les
certainement explications ya une petite
licorne là c'est ainsi une kelly en vdev
dit quel va être son cadeau de noël
normalement elle nous a dit
trois jours la boîte de jour
tout ça est chez elle devant vous avez
dit que vous inspiriez qu'à une chose
dans la vie c'est qui fait la vie
qu'elle sûr et le plus beau cadeau c'est
ne rien boire le lait comme le cap vers
le cap et away séjour au cap vert ainsi
céline sait que vous aimez voyager
anna est bien kelly s'est dit pourquoi
pas toi tu aviez prévu quoi cet hiver là
en décembre
rien du tout non rien du tout je vais
écouter kelly quatre ans je suis très
heureux pour vous
est ce que vous voulez la garder ou pas
cher prenez ce garder cette boîte
fonctionne ici parce que dans les bottes
vous pas pour savoir
je ne sais pas ce cadre les bois est ce
que vous avez rien je ne lis ça je n'ai
pas retiré lauréat du highway asie au
coeur faith ou pas y aller tu seras
jamais de grandes stars tapas titre dans
les idées vraiment que tu que vous
gardez ça sent le prime un truc comme ça
arrange pas à redon ce que vous garde
est-ce que vous gardez cette boîte des
fetwas la plateforme chez nous on n'a
pas à wade a examiné alors c'est bon
alors oui alors c'est là j'ai terminé
voilà trois ces termes il est fait n'est
séparé fait un beau cadeau c'est que ça
suffit
kelly vdev dit c'est quoi vous allez
avoir un costume de rabat
[Applaudissements]
super pas alors en vacances d'ailleurs
elle devra faire des photos sur un stade
avec toi dis ça c'est bien alors ça
c'est fait voilà je vous laisse là je
peux pas tout faire
je peux pas aller du simple et le poteau
derrière attentio aller s'ils veulent
ouvrir sa boîte il veut être face à son
cadeau de noël vas-y vas-y celle
d'arrivée des fêtards à moi parce que
s'il ya plus de temps je crois peuvent
faire maintenant voulait la nôtre à fait
moi je veux et j'ai eu en poche bien
avoir mon idée vous voulez l'a9
s'il vous plaît vraiment commis envers
la droite grecque
s'il vous plaît souper le règlement je
le fais minutes panne comme garde à vue
il a fait la leçon qu'on va la laisser
là neuf et très prisé aux maladies c'est
bien flash
allez vous arrange ou et 3 novembre
j'ai eu trois fans dans ma vie je gaba 3
et vous avez également trois coups
pratiques de formation
vous aimeriez avoir vu le toit tomber
cherry et j'habite au numéro 3 oui mais
est-ce qu'on peut faire mais trois fois
votre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
delphine est une amie même on est très
très amis dernier tome une soeur non
java sur la trottinette électrique
c'est le cas de votre cadeau à jamais
jean-michel mais ça serait un peu
n'importe quoi vous voulez une
trottinette électrique jean-michel je
vous ai toujours offert de beaux cadeaux
non non jean-michel êtes toujours offert
des salles cadeaux oui mais aujourd'hui
j'espère qu'ils la laddh que la retraite
il n'a pas vu la patte à passer aux
aveux rien
[Applaudissements]
camer sport high times après le times au
cap vert où il atteindra trottinette
électrique way you lie ça n'est pas là
trottier c'est un beau cadeau cas un bon
les huiles essentielles
[Applaudissements]
elle est contente elle l'art vient d'en
faire les allers chéri pour l'instant on
a deux cadeaux khoury annonce qui va
gagner son plus beau cadeau de noël
delphine est ce que vous les ouvrez
votre cadeau a du coup je garde le 10
mai à bastien delphine delphine a fuck
you there yet to be a bee been ya pas d
be a berné les verbes irréguliers
delsinne oui savait que celle sens bien
vous êtes beaucoup mois ci aussi les
secousses et des fines vient d'arriver
dans la bombe
déclinant rêve qui est animé semblait
revoit ses aliments pour animaux primés
à un prime de maintenant intelligente et
bienveillant c'est pas possible ça
bientôt de la chaîne aucun véto de la
chaîne si elle qui doit animer ce prime
time
delphine lamy bras se prend à peine si
on doit fermer la chaîne dernière la
scène avec wall on a vécu ça on a connu
des victoires on a connu des
dépassements sens et on l'a connu des
drames ces villes il ya moi j'y suis si
j'avais pris le lundi c'est ce que le
disent c'est un chiffre qui comprend
absolument pas d'accord je les prix
comme ça et vu que ça m'est venu je
pense que c'est ce qui m'a aiguillé
accueilli les prime et roger mais non
j'ai scellé où il est rusé veut faire un
break
c'est dingue une tête praticiens
prennent 6 et 1 prg m je cours je crois
à tous
bien un prime l finesse que vous gardez
là disent oui il est toujours définie
pour le bien de la chaîne à se regarder
la 80 à 10 comme ça dit oui 47 secondes
à la chapelle sin aller c'est un cadeau
qui vous correspond c'est un cadeau que
vous allez beaucoup aimé mais dis pas
que c'est le derby rennes n'était pas
dedans bel acteur de roger ça se fait
encore mieux quand c'est quelqu'un que
vous aimez énormément c'est le plâtre de
casta
[Applaudissements]
lien
flash donc je sais ouais je la sens bien
où ça veut dire quelqu'un axim que vous
avez choisi la boîte numéro 8
maxime crédit il est devenu depuis peu
mon petit chouchou
hier c'était pour qui jappe attrait des
montagnes celui pour qui j'irai au bout
de mes sur le mont everest et que je
créerai mon amour pour tout légué ni de
france ghani maximale c'est gagné qu'est
ce que vous aimeriez avoir comme cadeau
de noël un peu naïve et je ne suis pas
très gourmand mais joli trottinette
électrique me 13,2 et pour l'instant ils
veulent trottinettes électriques aux
cadeaux et si vous avez en prime vous
seriez déçu pas du tout heureux
maxime cazaux en tant que petit protégé
je ne sais pas ce qu'il ya dans la boîte
mais maxime j'ai tout fait pour envoyer
un fluide positif dans cette boîte est
apparemment le courant passe entre nous
maxime puisque c'est quoi non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est au bilan
j'essaie de lui à maintenir exactement
elles sont de bons procédés
on va ouvrir le cadeau de isabelle
morini bosc a eu peut-être qu'il verdez
gilles verdez comme vous voulez gilles
verdez très ferme
tout garder la boîte numéro 4 du verdet
telle loi de changer la classe 6 avec la
une
eclaron la 2 à 9 à 12 je crois que je
vais la garder parce que je vais aller
comme d'habitude au bout de mes idées et
je sens quelque chose ce cadeau ne
m'arrange pas et ce cadeau mais non
c'est vrai ça nous d'art
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
je vais devoir aller faire une carrière
sur gilbert mettre n'importe quoi dans
l'année bien sûr ce sera filmé en vie
d'albert des douits ça franchement je jo
c'était je suis pas comment je suis pas
comment réussit ça se passera bien
merci médiocre amiens était bien votre
boîte envie d'y aller il nous reste des
boîtes
c'est ce que je voulais c'est la 5e
médaille me donnez moi un bep données -
année - hymne benhaim benhaim est né en
1921 dans le nord du maroc
mais si aisément à ouarzazate
tu as quelques kilomètres de voir ça
mais naim
elle a deux passions dans la vie le
brochet je sais que c'est les boules est
malheureusement
malheureusement elle a des problèmes
gastriques et bien mettre en valeur
benhaim est-ce que vous gardez là cinq
attentats unanime
vous êtes ma soeur la plus proche de
cette émission vous êtes ma préférée
face à l'envolée depuis le plus
longtemps et a préféré aussi avec
isabelle et de voir avec daniel aussi
noté lee avec madame francesca elle
vient d'arriver et de rechange alors
béni oui oui je vais la garder
regardez la saint glin ouais ça passait
et soyez là il tient une chronique leur
l'assemblée d'ailleurs tous vous n'en
avez pas marre médaille mais qu'est ce
qui vous ferait plaisir voilà avec ce
qui reste maintenant j'aimerais bien sur
l'eau ou le séjour comme ça je peux
partir
le séjour avant la console de jeux pour
m mon seul bateau pour son frein ce pas
le niveau valérie bénaïm a un fils prime
le fils de valérie benaïm veut une
console de jeu alors qu'il a 54 ans où
chercher benhalima vous êtes ce soit le
prime un des piliers de ces huit vous
êtes benhalima aujourd'hui une personne
qui tient la chaîne à bout de bras
qu'est ce qui t'arrive et bien benhaim
journée parfaite tiendra encore plus
[Applaudissements]
on va maintenant s'intéresser à la boîte
numéro 6 daniel maurus daniel moreau
l'a6 l'assistent daniel l'araignée album
qu'est ce qui vous fait plaisir
alors moi je voulais dire quelque chose
si je gagne le cap vert évidemment vous
emmerdez pas à vous emmerdez pas peur
mais je veux bien mais si à roger avec
écouter avant la vie roger en trouve une
autre son coeur balance son coeur oui
son zizi nom d'albert ce que je pense de
toi tu as fait des compléments toute la
journée
alala alors ma chérie tu gardes la situe
peut la changer et au 1 allée du peuple
chinois
allez fais toi plaisir voilà 100 g dites
moi on n'est pas forcément on n'est pas
sur france 2 je m'en vais aller de la
chance je suis la première tant pis je
la sens alors que le ballon je suis né
dedans novembre le rose aller à gauche
ont changé avec le 11 10 bateaux premier
veto question pourquoi veto ricine bat
daniel robin dans la honte non parce que
c'est celle que je vais d'abord ouvrir
nos classiques puisque j'ai regardé pas
ou fait signer ce que tu ailles l'a6 tap
le droit de reprendre la route n'a plus
droit de retour n'a pas l'aura de
retoucher son père rappelleront touché
son père a touché la 11 tu veux la six
alors que se tient la 6c l'ats daniel
boxe mais je l'apprends suis fataliste
lataniers le box ouais ouais
c'est pas daniel n'écoute pas d'ici là
derrière la tartine bartholdi un très
beau cadeau christine tu gagnes à
console de jeux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle l'a eu une journée kdo de la une
c'est toujours celle que tu veux oui
fini le premier en sommes donc je sais
que tu adores la une
tu adores tf1 tu adoreras liste isabelle
est ce que tu veux garder la une bah oui
oui ma blessure fait ce que je voulais
c'est parce que encore dedans je vais
regarder les scènes à l'esp longue qui
sautent va prier pour qu'il sonne chez
toi remettre les plombs venir comme ça
bénévolement les visas belle s'il doit
aussi se doivent de chez toi je n'aurais
telles sommes donc je viens de te
remettre les plots et plus que vous ne
serez plus près votre présence que pour
votre humour
[Rires]
isabelle et voir sa tête
ah non aulas a déjà passé isabelle vous
espérez que ce n'est pas le cap bear
head quoi parce que j'aime bien les pays
froids et ben on peut faire le cap fois
[Rires]
isabelle moret soit il reste de beaux
cadeaux et trois cadeaux moins bien mais
moi moyens bonnets isabelle vous gardez
la boîte numéro une de chance sur cinq
donc j'aimerais avoir le prime time je
vais maintenant je vais me taper la
dernière box a d'abord s'annonce
d'autant plus que vous savez que daniel
et elles elles sont comme ça isabelle il
gagne un magnifique cadeau à dénier le
box non vous avez les voyages non c'est
la seule qui va gagner le voyage
incroyable si elle aime les voyages à
gagner les délices de tunis
[Applaudissements]
vous avez gagné un massage avec moyens
il faut avoir surtout ce soir de la
chambre n'est pour rien
il y a deux boîtes
je ne sais pas ce qu'il ya dedans seule
chose que je sais c'est que ces deux
personnes veulent bizarrement la boîte
numéro 13 des fuites chez certaines
personnes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ou bien c'est simplement parce que le 11
représente pour eux le graal gr.a à elle
l'a 9 la 11
on ne sait plus qui va avoir la neuve va
avoir la honte alors on a demandé
à vous oui vous les ronds de cuir
[Rires]
c'était à vous de décider ce soir
puisque c'est votre émission c'est vous
qui avez décidé qu'ils allaient avoir la
boîte numéro 9 et qu'ils allaient avoir
la boîte mayrand numéro 11
j'aimerais vous voulez toujours alors
peut-être que ce que voulait la 911
moi je garde l'a 9 oui bah t'es con quoi
faire voter les gens vous a si des gens
iront voter pour savoir si je devais
garder la norme et où l'on me régale
sinon on joue les toits on arrête les
modes alors oui quoi alors qu'on lui
avait dit que comment est arrivé
d'égalité parce que mais pas du tout
parce qu'elle couvrait à l'écouté et la
donne moi je veux la 9éme où on va
regarder lot
j'ai mobilisé les fan's et ben ce qui
doit pour la boîte murnau frémont des
fautes d'orthographe
des fautes de syntaxe à tout faire non
super vivre le sport local à tubize en
éclats c'est parce que tu te prendre un
chroniqueur bébé le prime d'hier quelque
chose de vérification du fait de dire
quelque chose qui est vraie parce qu'on
va m'accuser dîner mien je jure sur ma
lettre que j'ai pas triché j'ai eu un
flash cette nuit je sais pas en fait le
jeu des boîtes j'ai un flash que j'avais
un prime time
déjà ces officiers débarrasser de la
douze la nouveauté car tu sais où face à
la 12c thème déambulateur se
débarrassait de la douze je vais faire
quelque chose que je ne serai jamais
c'est que j'ai arrêté l'école à 15 ans
matthieu delormeau
c'est drôle je voulais c'est une
dernière est-ce que vous gardez la 11e
ou est ce que vous prenez la 9e thèmes
comme mass
eh bien on oublie pas qu à rien ça fait
deux gestes accomplis
ça fait demain je revis dooly's mon
flash mon frère était recroquevillé
comme ça c'était un neuf
[Applaudissements]
je te jure qu'il est vous qui décidez
est-ce que vous gardez la daf on n'a pas
le niveau ça moi je vais décider
non mais je garde la 9ème garder à
l'offre
garda est terminée gêne avant tu me vais
choisir les arènes lui qui avait la
nausée vu le terminer je garde la 9è ce
que c'est le prime time
mathieu
les gens le public est ce un échantillon
préféré que ce soit moi quel prix
matthieu delormeau s'était échouée qu'il
a au début vous la vouliez ce mois
depuis le début vous vouliez cette boîte
numéro 11
cette boîte dans laquelle peut-être et
daniel via il ya il y à cette émission
qui va peut-être vous faire passer un
simple oui vous avez déjà passé une
étape cette année passée l'autre
as-tu de l'emmo peut-être que vous allez
passer d'animateur de près access prime
time leader tnt leader sent-il
animateurs de prime time dernier tnt
revenant mathieu raymond c'est parce
qu'ils votent en prime caméra sur moi au
moment d'une caméra sur moi aller et ne
pas faire durer le suspense est donc
désigné monsieur
on chérit juge pose une dernière
question avec eux à la soirée mathieu je
te le jure
parce que jurait ce que tu veux me jurez
droit dans les yeux que tu n'as pas
tricher à mai sur mana sur ma life
non vraiment ils avaient la double
annonce pas de gens de la maison ça
voilà maintenant
mathieu comment ça se fait que vous
vouliez absolument la 11 j'appelle que
vous aviez déjà triché pour la laponie
paris c'est du tout s'il y avait eu des
rumeurs là dessus maintenant on vous a
fait défaut
non non non je choisis la de tubes a
demandé pourquoi la douleur sais rien
moi pourquoi la 11 parce qu'il y avait
qui avait quoi j'aurai le coup n'avait
pas triché
là je te jure enfin il faut lever la
main droite revient sur ces promesses ne
change pas il veut pas juré du moi
j'irai pour un prime time
béchir le jury de l'émission
je pense que mathieu de longs mois
tricher pour l'instant nous ne sommes
pas en mesure de le prouver mais mathieu
gras et non pour l'instant on pense que
tu as triché mais tant qu'on n'en est
pas sûr c'est quoi oui tu penses que
j'ai triché
bref tu le pense vraiment oui mais la
chose sauf si tu me pendant ce temps
autorisé à changer la boîte mais non à
ça prouve non parce que haarp après que
tu m'accuses d'avoir changé les boîtes
au dernier moment
tu as voulu la ronce depuis le début je
pense que c'est assez bizarre je pense
que tu avais des fuites
je pense que tu as encore subi au dessus
douaniers la prod les mecs en train de
perdre isabelle morini bosc
on a eu très peur
[Applaudissements]
hormis samy nacéri ça dans mon bébé tu
veux ça va j'ai prôné la non le roi la
fin vraiment quelle prime
alors j'ai pris alors tuyaux puis il ya
les bateaux va dire bye-bye je pense que
ma tu as triché mais mathieu mine de
rien pour l'instant où soit tu t'assois
à ben j'espère vraiment que tu n'as pas
triché arrêtez avec ça c'est très gênant
j'espère vraiment que tu n'as pas
tricher je tiens sur mathieu si tu as
triché tournure enquête mais tu va
animer une soirée chez daniel
[Applaudissements]
ouais
chat noir que je peux dire je veux dire
quelque chose juste moi je voulais un
truc je voulais le sos bab à ce qui
m'arrive de galère j'ai foiré le
radiateur d'huile de la voiture j'ai pas
de bagnole pour aller réveillonner je
vous le jure que ces histoires vraies je
veux bien donner nos prime à mathieu de
theniet il fera là daniel box est une